okay let's go ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to yo
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right ladies gentlemen welcome back
to the podcast I've got a great episode
today I recorded this episode many weeks
ago but putting it out now from the
Chappelle show from the wire from his
own podcast the fantastic and
charismatic was super funny ladies um
welcome terrifical Griffin
alright y'all welcome to the podcast
like I say mr. Donnell Rawlings um when
this all happened I didn't know who was
gonna be on the podcast who I'll be able
to get when I'll be able to get him so I
just banked as many episodes as I can
and you know I just I was I made a bunch
of calls I was like I get you on I got
to get you on but turns out people are
more available than I thought so I do
have a bunch of episodes banked and this
is one of them so this was from a few
weeks back but I'm putting it out now
it's still a great conversation and I
know you know you're out there right now
and we all have weird feelings you know
everybody's at different levels of
comfort everybody's at different levels
of financial security and I know people
out there having a tough time and even
the people that are not having a tough
time financially might still be having a
tough time emotionally I mean come on
there's so many things that were missing
out on but we you know we're not going
to restaurants we're not going to movie
theaters and we're not getting the inner
we can't go to sports we get all the
things that we use as an escape from our
crazy lives no matter what level you are
and finances those things are gone right
now so people like myself and content
makers we're just trying to put out
content and just know keep it going I
didn't realize how important it is and I
appreciate all the messages that people
send out to me about hey thanks for
doing the podcast thanks doing the
gaming and by the way if you want to
watch me stream some games I love doing
that too and that's it you can find me
on twitch and youtube at Eric Griffin
gaming so please come check that out
subscribe to those channels and you know
look we just we don't know how long this
is gonna be I mean I just found out that
you know I'm in LA County and they're
talking about we're gonna be in a stay
at home order till August so wow it's
just it's it's unbelievable
unprecedented time so we're all here
together trying to do the best we can
and thanks for listening to the show
like I appreciate you're watching right
now and I really appreciate it
appreciate the messages I appreciate all
that stuff and I'm just gonna continue
to keep putting out content and you know
let's see what happens I mean this is
the world we live in now so let's get
used to it or even if we don't want to
get used to it let's at least figure a
way to live through it so this is one of
those ways is to continue to do my show
and I have
great guests on please enjoy mr. Donnell
Rawlings boom there we go hey welcome to
the show mr. Donnell Rawlings and his uh
My Mind's telling me yo this won't get
out more right now this is my son my son
says he has his own phone his home
studio phone he said that this call was
gonna be his first phone call I say
what's up what up say hello come on man
this is my my friend on podcast yeah all
right so you're not doing good to be off
the top of this you go get ready for
virtual school I'm gonna talk to this
dude this dude has taken a lot of money
out of your mouth this guy one looks so
nice and friendly
money right here Eric Holder did it all
right so you go work on your project let
me go to work I love you I'm not gonna
wear all right we'll stay right here
just stay right here
yeah so you do a whole house schooling's
how's that how's that doing home school
how is that
you're out you know everybody know they
call me a Dino dead i'ma older dad I'm a
Dino dead you know my friends grandkids
are same age as my son but I will say
one thing
odors from preschool of three men that's
the difference between my friends and me
right there but I will say it's a lot
easier doing I'm homeschooling when you
do it ABC's I'm murder ABC yo I act like
I'm Stein of ABC's you've got to do ABCs
yo I stick the 80s heart I stick the B's
heart sees I go in all upset well that's
good that's good to hear
so is it like you have to like zoom into
his classes like how does that work or
you like I mean how does a white people
out there well he just wants to be out
of my face it's like you know my son's a
preschool right so they did never this
is the one thing about on the cabrona
whole situation with closed down stuff
some people weren't prepared for it you
know I mean like the school day he goes
to it's a pretty established school some
well well toilet educated educators but
that's when a in this regular normal
environment that's what an environment
like okay I can touch you I can see you
I can body language I can help control
you whatever but now you go from that
type of curriculum to okay now we got to
engage these three and four-year-olds
the same way like us engaging nouns
through like a monitor right whispered
it's been it's been challenging but for
me with him because he's starting rebel
school in the fall I didn't want him as
traumatic as this situation could be for
kids I didn't want him to lose his
social skills I didn't want him and not
to talk to his friend that goes to
school where they are useful they share
orange not anymore we all share oranges
no boy yeah you keep where everybody got
their own lunch box and that's lucky
yo I told myself or snacks a year what's
in your safe but it's like it's a new
it's it's going to be it is already a
new world and as much as everybody
Erica's like this cuz you and have
talked about it like I can trust you you
did trust me don't wait I don't trust
your kid listen how you know I said cuz
it was funny because when we was doing
this when we first planned on doing this
we both was making out like this did you
feel like this before this with their
you know how you know your your your
successful comedian and more importantly
you got a name where you could work the
road do whatever go get some money when
you want right yeah and I know you've
been this situation like your agent I'm
up yeah you want to take that weak
enough like yeah I played three weeks
you know let me go take a break right I
don't know when they started when they
start clapping that mandate down my leg
took my why you look so upset what I
write I said Donald Trump just said it's
no live performances for three months
that like we get you know luckily like
I'm frugal you know I'm sure cuz you got
kids that you but you let you know you
always got to put money away but you
always got you always got a always have
four sons
you always got subway and more important
these are people who understand this
would whole thing put money where's one
thing you have to do that but you always
have to know how to make money yeah
figure it out you know somebody people
think it no all I'm gonna do is gonna be
so and so and I understand that but the
ones that make it some people that get
inspired get motivated and come up with
something to make money during times
like this yeah I mean I've said it's so
easy it's easy so so easy for you and I
to say man I need like man oh man what
I'm gonna do I can't wait my shuttles
come all we could say and this is where
white people I know half of you knew
this way remember what I told you about
the podcast I came with you real did
you're here you know how to tie no you
said it like it was a good drug coming
yeah yo you was like this then you you
yo you look you feel like this you feel
like this you your eyes this ship you
this why you be got a rope you did like
this so you look around like this you
dill I did you look like come here come
here come here
that's it what side you wanna go on your
right side of your black yo sounds like
what you talked to your black ear your
white ear you'd love to be like this
[ __ ] the black ear right now but it's
gonna guess come down white money oh
yeah man you got that's what you gotta
go in each time and you know I
appreciate it
cuz a lot of people they selfish Bert
Kreischer Theo von Chris Lee all them to
just try to keep the podcast [ __ ] to the
white community son ha figured it out so
they knew this got them they knew was
coming on Sunday they ha ha ha
what but I mean a real problem world the
real issue with it is more it's not even
just a people to do it is to people
listening I mean it's like we gotta get
like the urban black Latino communities
to get invested in podcasts and I just I
don't know if they are not you know I
just don't know what you'll just do one
thing at a time like two or three no
it'd be different type of Negroes to no
no no we already got to York I will pass
right away for a less threatening Negro
to come down here yeah but you know what
what I never took it I think I didn't
know about it like when you was telling
me about it
you was just getting excited about in
exercise and I think one of the things I
got you excited about it was you like it
is a way to make money but it's another
outlet platform to be funny
yeah this is like yeah not many free
common faces I gave wait you're thinking
about this thing you ever cause my
beautiful over-whip part 1 & 2 what a
teaser and go to the patron page yes
from say this just it's like it's a new
world but it's not even a new world it's
actually turning into this is our world
right now yes but you know what if you
think about as much as people frustrated
so much you can't go out this way you
can't go out that way and like
everything that works social distancing
right yeah the average millennia with
those who disappear self from everything
anyway yeah yo Amazon was building
building building we was getting built
with it Amazon a week no [ __ ] you get
off the phone and this [ __ ] dumb
Amazon you don't say online dating
online shopping malls the only reason
people is going to malls is to get plan
yeah and when you was dating when you
were dating yeah it's not even like you
were like to meet you wasn't even like
you were meeting people in person like
like how many times are people dating
and they on their apps for life weeks
months at a time before they actually do
anything anything on the dates I know
that on it so we was partially prepared
for it but like the whole thing is like
you know you prepare for it like yeah
you know it's like when something's
about to happen you got your hurricane
save a life kit and you get all this
[ __ ] ready there it didn't go but you
really don't think is gonna really pop
off right I'm the one yet biggest I was
it deeply maybe we wait for hurricane
like oh yo [ __ ] get charcoal [ __ ]
been eyes yes my biggest is going to
grab me wish they gonna get cramps
[ __ ] get Domino's I don't know what it
was El Nino it was one of them
listen I was at DC right and one of my
brothers he's a brilliant dude Brown
University of Georgetown Law right so
he's the type of [ __ ] that noticed [ __ ]
coming
he got disaster preparedness plans good
enough saying like yeah he got like
Louis signs he do [ __ ] like in the event
we were all meet here this they got
flashlights all this type of [ __ ] right
so we waiting for this [ __ ] to pop off
right we like is it coming is we love we
as a company as I manage it and come to
we heard just [ __ ] we ran a house all
the lights went out right and everybody
think I played too much my brother this
[ __ ] get everybody else a flashlight
this [ __ ] give me a Yankee scented
candles you just have to straight candle
know what he in the jar and it was a
lavender joint
it was so yo I'm like you I'm looking
like man when we gonna stop beefing his
over bra yeah but you know like you're
not talking man like it well it comes
down to it what we gonna do I know and
it was so [ __ ] up and I know why you a
dirty [ __ ]
right this way you're dirty [ __ ]
right no I'm just saying you are you are
it's not a work day of working after all
right right try to be non-print yeah
like you like like you literally you
[ __ ] and I don't give you props for
nothing but you is one thing to be funny
understand or whatever but to be a
working actor and be able to get and
continue to get like [ __ ] know you as
the acting funny [ __ ] yeah I know I
don't people and even know me as a
standard that's how sad it is sometimes
but it you know what but I know then you
got to go both ways
yeah in a case like this if it like me
personally [ __ ] like I'm literally
unemployed mm-hmm you don't say I don't
have a series right now understand I
know but the art not the odds of you
working in that you want to catch
something you're not mean like not know
Corona [ __ ] you cuz you good at it you
know I'm saying you establish face
people know you work at this you gonna
know I know this may sound crazy I'm not
a psychic you're always gonna find
acting work you made me want to get fed
you just rude that's just you were
talking about disrespectful you know
this story you come up to me you kill
Jimmy say yeah I was up I was up for
that part but there was a weight
restriction and then you just walked
away
congratulations on that part I was up
for but there was a weight restriction
that's just disrespectful
we got cancelled anyway - we only did
two seasons no but two seasons in three
years man you know it was a lot the
grass is always greener on the other
side man people look at you know you
don't mean I do understand what you're
saying
but this will people don't understand he
said only two seasons I remember years
ago when I was doing HBO's the wire some
time ago right still of people still
kind of remembered and I remember like
as hard as I work to position myself to
get an audition to be considered for
something like that to have an agent
because you know like them open calls
though usually cut it's like you know I
got so and so and so and so and then
like when I did the wire and I was like
out when I did when I auditioned I need
no distant just guess the East Coast it
was East Coast and West Coast it was
whoever was a cop [ __ ] with the top
agency you know I'd go yeah yeah and I
looked at for me to get it and didn't be
a part of their show they go on to give
success to this unlimited rolling but
somebody told me why they say yo what
number on what's the number two - why I
want to do that like it's a it's a a
hotline just to call the wire and just
be on a wire like oh yo yeah hi yeah did
you that's have my mom you should think
about it - my mom will be like yeah why
don't you want an NBC show can't you
just call you know oh yeah let me can
you patch me through to the people that
book shows because my mom I think I
should be on this show and that's why I
always like you don't know what you
think about somebody skillset is you
know you got a big hats off to people
that that once you see somebody on the
show like it's for show time
man they have to beat out a lot of
people one just you versus one person
well you know what though but you know
what though sometimes though I mean it's
skill luck and opportunity those things
come together you never know because the
you know how I got on I'm gone up here
the producers in Jim Carrey at the
Comedy Store one night on a Tuesday and
they saw me perform then I got an
audition the next day and I was on the
show three weeks later so but you never
know you just never know how it happens
man
what did the but you never know happens
but again that's an example of giving
yourself every opportunity when people
move from different cities and stuff
what you just said is what people live
for yeah yeah people and that's what
makes the Comedy Store stage what it is
of course you like the fans mm-hmm but
the opportunity that somebody might just
be sliding through a producer in BAM
that's what that's what keeps on the
comedy lab let's we keep you alive even
working that working a circuit and doing
it right writing the money the money's
just like what you need just to live but
we don't it's not the main thing it's
like all these things we do kind of
connect so if you think about it like
keep the Hat on and take it off well who
is shiny as hell let's go
nobody starts taking the Jeffersons
theme yeah look I got all type of dude
look this Buster right he is as funny as
you and me both got this going on to
worse I got is so great I don't know
this is so great this my hairline well I
don't call it ball you do different
words don't call the ball I'll say
there's parts how long you were left in
a man movie Rose he was 22 always there
to hold the thing of that the picture so
old is black and white
[Laughter]
they try to figure out your age they're
just gonna let he got a grown son how
does that work you know I mean but you
know what man is how you feel bruh you
know it's how you feel especially in
this world like acting you don't say any
day it is what it is and I'm telling you
[ __ ] like this corona [ __ ] make my
father's realize me am i trippin off
that [ __ ] or my really everyday trying
to live the best that I can
I totally agree man yo son the worst
thing you do is you being petty with
somebody and some some tragic happen
yeah especially with this Ronit type of
[ __ ] going on there
[ __ ] that might be the last time you
see somebody yeah the only thing only
thing you're gonna get only thing you're
gonna get is my [ __ ] memories so what
do you want them to be let me ask you
this let me ask you this like the last
year and a half I thought it's been some
of the best time in standup you know we
have some of the best specials come out
some of like the people were selling
tickets all over the place and yet do
you think we're gonna get back to that
because you know dude when we go see
Chappelle do a special again you know I
mean when we go see this guy from his
car right there Bobby buy it but you
gotta look at it like this bro it's
gonna be certain certain you know it's
certain one of a certain of in-out feel
to just they got to do it they don't
like this flight how people go see go to
therapy yourself therapy that's when I'm
mad at my relationship yeah you know
stage when I'm having relationship I
gotta get on stage me too you know
that's like some people it don't fuel it
they don't have to do it some people I
give you example Chris Tucker and I love
Chris Tucker
you know Sam but and I've been around
you could tell Chris Tucker doesn't have
the passion to stand up anymore right
right
you're not saying nothing he can't do it
a do well but like he said in one time I
think when we had the mark twain was
like yeah y'all muhfuckas off all the
time and part of his probably tougher
for him to being like a really religious
person the atmosphere that's consist
it's kind of a dark thing it's dark in
this alcohol remember when you tried to
open up that ridiculous non alcohol
comedy club oh yeah it was enough look
at God no man nobody want to go to now
you need it supposed to be a place you
let loose at night yeah yes yeah
nighttime Church no but I know he's like
who you saying just some of us did like
but see I feel like I like at first when
this happened the first couple weeks man
this [ __ ] has been hard because I have
no creative outlet and I need that you
know like going on stage yeah you got
yeah you do you just gotta reship what's
right that's what I'm doing but I'm just
saying that first it's like you know cuz
you know that like when you go
you go you leave your family you leave
your kids you leave your girl and then
you go and it's just that kind of
release of all that all that stuff and
then you can go back and you feel saying
again we don't have that we have to
refocus how you guys doing how have you
been doing it I've just been redirecting
it you know like for years I told myself
because I got a young son I told myself
oh man the road is getting burnt down oh
you don't want to swim without my son
but I was never just gonna stop because
it's my only source of income you know
I'm saying as crazy as it was if there
was some delight of Corona this qur'anic
and image for me is like I've never this
is the most time I've been with my son
Cosette consecutively since he was born
so I got that part of it and then like I
really am excited about my podcast I'm
really excited about the growth of it
and everything yeah but with this shot
with me on the road sometimes you know
how it is like I'm gonna tape onto well
I won't be back in the studio you might
news a week or you might lose two weeks
and like I can't do that you gotta be
conservative but now it's like now it's
like I got so much time to really really
put push my brand yeah so in the event
of something like this happens that I've
already established having other income
it's too easy to get caught like a Road
Dogg yeah man I got work all year but
but you know what's happening I was
talked about this already with a few
other people but I want to talk to with
you about this see um we you know a lot
of people like that who they also make a
good living on the road right yeah but
they still live in like gig to Gig even
if they make enough nice money and they
spending that money every week like
people live at beyond they means out
here in our profession and they're all
and now it's like what do they do you
know call you
I'm afford him your kids number are
gonna call you like everything you know
I'm Kelly mess but I love the people
check it in and make sure I'm good at
whatever man we're next to the stop I
just listen man I hope this letter finds
you I'm like oh here we go yeah
yeah hey let me um let me holla at you
for a second about holding something you
know I mean like I did you know and I
know in cases some people need that I
mean some people need a little help and
a lot of cases some people need just to
try harder think deeper like yeah people
gonna say oh it's easy for y'all to say
but everybody had problems yeah
somebody's somebody that's used to
making money if all of a sudden they're
used to making money and they just
paying bills paying bills and then the
money coming in they know that [ __ ]
they're gonna be like they were like
just hold up hold up
we gotta slow it down like Darnell here
life was like check this out - they
think that we got some kind of
retirement plan - it don't work like
that like we got to work that's why your
own tasks are still out there on the
road
there's no 401k for comics but the
reason why I gotta keep working because
again I haven't felt my lane to like you
know I haven't felt that Lane like money
comes but it's like I hadn't found that
Lane where I like like can do it without
stand up on these stand up but this
right here this is making me sick more
as a real business
as with merchandise and - how me and my
brand can make money it's gonna make
people think a lot deeper and it's gonna
make people strong is gonna make to the
weak weaker yeah I agree man I well said
I totally agree with that man
have you been have you been like have
you been binge watching television shows
and stuff like that like what are you
doing no no like what I've been doing is
like I got certain certain rotation of
like going a laughs usually my day
consists of I get up I get up really
really early right right
and I quarantine myself the crib and the
car and when I said a car is - like I
have a routine I'd like to just drive
like about a half-mile you know hit the
7 them get coffee and I just think and
at that time you know I still got a lot
of connections on the East Coast so I
called people on the East Coast nice
early if you look weird in LA but like
right when they're getting energized and
I oh I'm up I'm up I'm knows
that's the most columns in the most
peaceful time for me so I'm connecting
with people on East Coast whatever
business issues I have if I just want to
talk to family members on the East Coast
I'm up early enough to do that get them
why they're working and then once la
starts to get up I bug these
[ __ ] you know I get you know
and I did I get my sons up I wake up I
waked everybody up and then I make my
sons on breakfast get him ready for his
virtual school you know go to virtual
school with him and then after I go to
virtual school am usually like the time
we're doing this down and I have been
getting a lot of requests for interviews
but I've kind of a lot at that time from
like two PST to like four five to do
podcast did I start helping my son with
without cooking dinner stuff getting
them ready and that's the whole day you
know that's a solid day and I can adjust
any kind of way I want because I still
control my schedule but with this and I
even encourage people you know you got
young kids would ever try not to disrupt
the routine too much it can't feel like
it can't feel like a party or birthday
it's got to feel like oh man I gotta do
what I was doing but it's this way now
yeah I know yes that's why I try to keep
because you can't you gotta have some
type of structure do you start feeling a
sense of hopelessness right you know
what I know what you're saying I've like
so I make myself that's why I'm doing
this man that's why I'm hitting people
up like yo come on my podcast let's
let's do this and then I
I've been cooking more like I've never
cooked as much as I'm cooking right now
yeah nobody man I know I got a little
off earlier but when aronia was first
Bobby right we went when we went to
block the road you like Nick you do the
block just come through we go to address
right yeah I did show up we could do a
phoner already
he was like [ __ ] just say no yeah I'm
just like I'll try to tell people like I
understand how hard it is for people to
want to do podcast not everybody wants
to do it cuz there's so many and people
got their own thing so I always tell
people I try to tell them I try to tell
people like look if you if you can't do
I'm okay with no you know me like that's
all I'm saying that's a I just get
people acting like like everybody's home
right now so if you're not answering
your phone you just don't want to talk
to me you know we never owned a call
coming yeah so you know it is what it is
but I don't tell you Dells or does
something really recipe was like me I
don't like I said I'm gonna be one of
them [ __ ] or do my podcast right and
then I'm like I don't really ask people
to do the podcast it's just like I just
talk about [ __ ] and I yeah I've seen
your tanks and it's like when I tell
people to tell any lazy buggers I was
like when I first came out this I was
like it's to react this is a reality
show about a podcast now saying yeah I
find I find somebody not showing up and
getting the argument with me is
entertained enough to make it complete
episode out of it you know I like this
you know people don't understand
Housewives of Atlanta fire but let's get
those to cardio yeah yeah but it's like
I always looked at it like it's man I
got so many but I got some big ideas for
his podcast from my intro I took my
intro was real serious you know the
relationships I've built and when I
first started I knew I didn't know what
I was doing I knew it certain times I
talked too much and it was [ __ ]
trolling the [ __ ] out of me son
now I remember when I got a first
aspired out I was leaving Joe Rogan's
podcast and I thought I had we I just
thought we had just won the greatest
podcast me history a podcast right man
ma'am Rogan hug that that he said this
one you could hug him make it right but
he's probably less hug on camera right
it was like sweaty palm you know and he
said man cuz RZA went out with a free
stay he said man that might be one of
the greatest
outros in podcast history and I was like
where he said I was I was all happy
he said Daniel oh and remember whatever
you do he said don't read the comments
you know what I did you went right to
the comments [ __ ] I read I can't read
those Rogen comments
like animals they're animals I didn't
read I think only read like 3275 right
before I said I shouldn't read anymore
right
yeah man but but with that I took some
of the things some people said as
constructive criticism how's that you
know what you know what you might be
kind of right
I do get overzealous sometimes maybe if
I would listen to stay in the pocket you
know I'm saying it helped me work on my
listening skills you know I'm saying
with because right now you're a better
guest than you are a host that's what it
is
nah I think I'm good at both up [ __ ]
[ __ ] is you talking about this better at
one I didn't say he was bad at the other
I feel that whatever big what did you
say
[Laughter]
a very expecting us to be down for two
three months whatever it is I looking
like that's a good time for me to
connect with my son and really go hard
with promoting the down there on the
show and making it fire yeah about this
how about this [ __ ] working on a
podcast [ __ ] right now and already
developing the TV show and they say okay
and we're back on and go right to work
yeah I know that's what that's what I
you know I think the people that are
really focused are the ones that are
really trying to do it but what are you
brushing you have you ever done that
like 20 to do this I'm so happy
math shaved my must I shaved my mustache
off is good things growing back right
now but I just they meant us to do like
what is going on around here that's
crazy it is what it is
yep so we gonna get back on the circuit
so so you know what it is yeah what do
you think in your bag if you had to
guess when do you think it will honestly
be back in comedy club I think I don't
think completely back home got things no
bunch of smaller venues but when a lot
of things that people are not
considering with this virus and
viruses in particular is that you know
like once we start like which is very
still kind of cold across the country
you know I'm saying yeah I think once we
start getting to the point like we
started getting them 85 and 90s in heat
wave it's gonna slow the spread of it
down and slowing it spread up the down
means you don't won't be so many people
dying whistles gonna give people a
little bit more confidence to go out but
not so much go out and be regular would
never be rebel no more but to live your
life within those new guidelines there's
gonna be new guidelines yeah like I
think someplace like the Comedy Store
the main the main room we'd be able to
open up because you just have tables and
then you have everything six feet apart
so you can have more people in a bigger
room than say us a smaller room like I
don't see the oh are opening up because
it's not gonna be feasible but like I
guess see the main room be in the place
because you could just spread people out
well they're not gonna still gonna come
like first off it's gotta be it's gonna
have to be quicker testing procedures
that's what I was saying to you they
whistle from - a week - five - three -
45 - got 15 like a pregnancy test
it's gotta be like a pregnancy test you
know you just like put it on the tongue
you like oh [ __ ] I got it I gotta go oh
oh I love clear see that's so you were
traveling man yeah you gotta have clear
you know because we have you know but I
prefer the eye because my fingers never
do it right my fingers I do it - I -
somebody I don't like what they say make
your eyes bigger I'm like all right they
could just use my fingers man yeah you
know the doctors like I'm a darkening or
so so the second of the ID means a lot
to me you never had my eyes our eyes are
cool and a vaccine [ __ ] go back to you
that's all people experiment this come
probably some people are kind of risky
but until they be like this [ __ ] they
got a shot for it you know I'm saying
like I agree I totally agree I don't say
don't think like sports and
entertainment are truly gonna come back
until there's a vaccine yep you know and
then when listen example a doctor CB
join us up that's the same three moms
[ __ ] that'll give me liquor road yes so
it has to be some sort of like like
preventive care or some kind of like you
know some kind of like like the day
they're gonna make theraflu even better
where if you know Eric do preventive
care it's taken the precautions that
we're taking now tonight you're sick you
now said we think about it laughter Neal
Brennan I know I know that we [ __ ]
deal Brendan had it right all along we
was like we was like we was like hood
[ __ ] making fun of a [ __ ] the
scholarship how about this how about
this how many times were you at the
airport and you made fun of Asian people
to have masks on they had to be passed
on and they had masks off for years
Oh every time I saw I was like maintain
up I ordered no people brought me to the
mall for the surgical masks they act now
I'm but no Idol at Asian people from now
on but you know why you know why they
knew the same way we gonna know now they
live through it yeah
but they've been doing that for years
man right then do this [ __ ] yeah man
yeah but it was good my honey you know
we're gonna get like it's gonna is that
is good there's gonna be some tragedies
it's gonna be some things you know
people not gonna be able to understand
whatever but with all its gonna be is
gonna be a learn this first they don't
think you can do is try to get better
then do better yes I agree I agree I
think it's chanting and I also think I
think it's strengthening you know
relationships things making people work
on themselves it's making people already
live in their lives you know I mean it's
it's driven it's great
yeah well you know you need to know if
this ain't the one now you know you'll
figure it out if I can't be with you
like if you ain't pandemic boo you never
mean you ain't gonna be regular boo but
I actually think that the whole world
should shut down for a week every year
I'm it's doing wonders for the
environment it's doing wonders for like
you know we're not to this point where
it's crushing the economy but just every
year I should go are we taking a
vacation everybody has to stay indoors
for a week and reset oh that would be
that would be so dope that that would be
so dope man that's crazy and brilliant
idea at the same time I know but it just
it takes something like this I almost
feel like it's like and then here in
California it's like so we got this we
get to stay at home order which we were
to do it so I'm like yeah I use a scarf
you know yeah oh man what do you know
it's like hopefully you'll be able to I
mean that's such an iconic thing for you
like look I was wrong workaholics and it
was like I'm always gonna be Montez from
workaholics you know I mean it's like is
so you were a part of something great
also you know cuz like kids still watch
workaholics today and it's like their
favorite show but you are a part of
something so iconic and like how does
that
do you think about that often do your
time with on Chappell and the
relationship you have with him now every
day and when I say that netsim day to
dwell on it but it's so funny because I
shall became so engraved into pop
culture so engraved into a new form of
comedy with meme and means and stuff
like that it became that popular that
it's like if as much as you want to
forget about it something's gonna come
up if then you know in this business
it's so hard to be recognized by
anything so the minute you can people
can recognize it at the end of the day
what happened that it can put people in
the seats I can't be mad at that it was
it was one of the things that people
connect with and then I got to see the
other things I did and see where my work
ethics are and that uh [ __ ] funny and
now noticing now too that like
Chappelle's like how many years ago was
that now like 15 so so what's cool about
that now is that you know new people are
finding it but it's also like you know
the kids are like older now so you know
you know I mean like I have to people
people come to me tell my man I grew up
you and this [ __ ] got like a kid my
Sundays I might do you know we've been
in people's lives for a long time it's a
strange thing but it's hard to be ready
I take it like to be a part of like
something like okanagan something that
for the most part will go down in
television history you know I was a part
of the wire one of the most critically
acclaimed television shows in the
history of television and Chappelle's
Show so you know if nothing else when I
leave here whatever I'll be a part of
history that way my son and know that
and people be like yo there's some cool
stuff you know yeah man for sure you
sure Dan you sure damn did man well look
man I I hope we get back you know I hope
you know hope hope is slavery am yeah
but what I'm saying those like you know
you even when I'm looking at TV right
now and I'm looking at say whatever show
and then on that show I'm seeing all the
extras on the show and then maybe
there's like a scene where there's like
you know at a mall and there's a lot of
people in the scene and I'm thinking to
myself what is the entertainment
business gonna look like in the near
future like
is it all gonna be like all the scenes
are gonna be everybody six feet apart
I'm telling you that the people of Phil
people will start to feel a little more
comfortable under certain circumstances
people gonna six feet but it's something
gonna have to it's gonna have to be a
bad scene it's tough to come along like
they've got catch an RBI you know you
don't say like yeah you know then happen
with it happen with age people don't
roll the dice like that but I played
with the last time you hear about
somebody dying from AIDS you know like
like this treatment is preventive things
it's like gonna get fun again they get
those commercials on right now about
that stuff like you know you know you
live it with Hanes and you can you won't
get you you know even if you have it
you're not gonna spread it you know so
you gonna get herpes gonorrhea and
everything else but you look like
20-some years no but they think they
work it fast on this flu vaccine I think
we got every scientist in the world is
working on this [ __ ] right now
maybe somebody don't come up with that
but we'll think about it what is crises
like this think about the scientists the
money making I know people like but what
about the people yeah but they still
want to make money so my knee making to
whoever get it let me get them good and
I want to bid best in that company right
away I hope they put it out how I get
because some stockings at that company
trench coat what you need what you need
like you need a ventilator but we're
gonna get to it it's gonna take people
like you myself people it's true to this
like where people where they try to
always always try to tell kameez Oh
everything funnier the funny yeah [ __ ]
what a doctor's everything serious yes
what a lawyers everything words yes
anything it's funny without that's what
we do we don't think like y'all
[ __ ] we don't think we had a
funeral like we looking for a joke but
we know is one in there yeah just funny
you say that you know that's so funny
you say that you know the first time
that I knew I could be a working
comedian was I
was speaking at a kid's funeral you know
and you know I'm crying and then I had
to like talk about him and when I
started talking about him man I was
killing this funeral and I was like oh
[ __ ] I was like I could do this for a
living I could do this because I had you
know it was funny I tell my comedian
friends about that and they are like who
books that who's the book that funeral
so I'm just telling you man no no the
book Annette Korona they'll be booking
that job but you know what's weird
though is like would you say about like
we're not like you we're not like normal
people and that's why most of my friends
are comedians is because you can't be
around regular people and then you say
something off-putting and they don't
understand where you're coming from and
it's not their fault and I don't blame
them I'm just saying banal yeah you know
I mean we just we just think about
things differently I happen to have I
have a joke in every moment you know
they gotta say I did this is a thing I'm
your hero because my son is actors for
attention this is I gotcha and it's been
with my clock has the donnell rawlings
show and I encourage people to follow it
to subscribe to it straight whatever but
my line I in every show not every show
but what I do that I'm matter a joke
could be too soon but it never could be
too soon for funny observation
that's what we do so yeah I totally
agree
all right everybody just been down there
Rollins and I and if thanks man and
we'll talk soon all right I appreciate
you my [ __ ] yeah do talk soon